hey 42 here just one pint of donated
blood is enough to save three lives the
blood you donate is actually sold on the
open market and the blood industry is
worth four point five billion dollars
per year but blood saves lives if he
began donating blood at the age of 17
and donated every 56 days until you
reach 76 years old you will have saved
more than 1,000 lives but not everyone's
blood is the same Hollywood movies and
TV shows regularly remind us that before
someone can undergo a blood transfusion
medical professionals must find out that
person's blood type and match it with a
suitable donors blood type but why what
would happen if you were given the wrong
blood type what even is a blood type and
why do we have them to begin with let's
find out there are four major blood
types a B a B and O blood type is
hereditary and which one you have
depends on your parents if both parents
have a blood type the child will most
likely have an a blood type as well
similarly B and B type parents will
produce offspring with B type blood
however if one parent is a type and the
other B type the child will have a B
type okay that's all quite simple but
things get trickier when we introduce
the Oh blood type A and B blood types
are dominant genes or alleles to be more
precise whereas the allele responsible
for Oh blood type is recessive this
means if one parent has an O blood type
and the other parent has either an A or
B blood type then the child is most
likely to have either an A or B blood
type - in order for someone to have an O
blood type both their parents have to
have Oh blood types - making o blood
types extremely rare and highly
sought-after in the medical field
there's also another reason why donors
with an O blood type are desired so much
but we'll get to that later
it's all very well labeling them with
letters but what does your blood type
actually say about your
what makes a type blood different from B
type blood well it all has to do with
what type of sugars and proteins sit on
the red blood cell antigens are proteins
or sugars that attach themselves to the
membrane of red blood cells
an antigen acts as an identifier to your
immune system there are many different
varieties of antigens and each has their
own unique signature a way of
identifying itself to your own immune
system I'm sure you've heard of
antibodies they're the little armored
Knights of our bodies whenever a foreign
object enters our bloodstream the immune
system instantly dispatches antibodies
like flying ninja monkeys they then make
their way around our body and attach
themselves to cells if they find a cell
that wasn't created by our own body such
as an evil pathogen then the antibody
exterminates it but how does the
antibody know which cells belong to our
body and which are foreign intruders
well that's where antigens come in
antigens have a unique configuration
that our immune system is familiar with
when an antibody attaches to a cell it
does this by connecting with the cells
antigens if it recognizes the
configuration of the antigen it kindly
buggers off and leaves it in peace but
if it can't successfully attached to the
antigen because it has a configuration
at the antibody isn't used to it
destroys the cell instead it's kind of
like the antigen and the antibody show a
unique password and only by exchanging
that password will the antibody leave
the cell alone there are two types of
antigen a and B and the combination of
those a and B antigens that sits on your
red blood cells determines your blood
type someone who only has a antigens on
their cells is said to have an a blood
type similarly having only B antigens
means you have a blood type of B if you
have a mix of both a and B antigens on
your cells then you have an a B blood
type people with an O blood type however
do not have any A or B antigens but they
don't have a antigens either because
there's no
think they instead have no antigens at
least within the system because Oh
blood types don't have antigens on their
cells they are known as universal donors
this means their blood can be given to
anyone with any blood type and it will
be accepted by the recipient body this
is because an o-type blood cell doesn't
have any antigens on it so the
recipients antibodies don't have any way
to attach to the blood cell and identify
it what normally happens when a patient
receives a blood transfusion is that the
antibodies are dispatched to latch on to
foreign blood cells and detect whether
it has an A or B antigen upon it if the
foreign antigens match the antigens of
the recipients own blood then the body
accepts the new blood in gets on with it
for example a recipient of a blood type
of a can only receive blood with a
antigens or no antigens as is the case
with Oh tight blood similarly B blood
types can only receive blood with B
antigens or no antigens people of an a B
blood type however are able to receive
blood with no antigens a or b antigens
or even a combination of both because
their antibodies are set up to recognize
and accept both a and B antigens a B
blood types are therefore known as
universal recipients because they can
receive any blood type if someone
receives a blood transfusion of the
wrong blood type and their immune system
rejects it for example of an a blood
type receives B type blood then the
results can be catastrophic if you are
given the wrong blood type the first
thing you will experience is a feeling
of impending doom yes that is actually a
genuine medical symptom that feeling of
impending doom will also be accompanied
by severe flu-like symptoms the cause of
these symptoms is your immune system
attacking the following blood cells
your body's antibodies will detect that
the antigens of the foreign flawed do
not match the type of antigens of your
own blood cells and so it kills them the
attack which ensues upon the foreign
blood cells is both quick and aggressive
when foreign blood cells of a different
blood type are being killed off it sort
of
fit read the dead blood cells can
accumulate in the veins and cause a
blood clot this is known as an acute
hemolytic transfusion reaction and it
can very quickly kill someone because of
this hospitals are extremely careful and
blood type mismatches happen very rarely
but when they do the resulting fertility
rate is high if you think that blood
type seemed rather simple well I'm sorry
to tell you there's a little more to it
than I have been letting go so up to now
we have four blood types a B a B and O
however there are actually eight blood
types at least within the system
those are a positive a negative B
positive B negative a B+ a B negative
o+ and O Negative so where do the
positives and negatives come from well
they come from a third type of antigen
called the Rh factor named after rhesus
monkeys in which it was first identified
your blood cells either have the Rh
factor antigens or they don't it's as
simple as that
if the Rh factor antigens are present
then you have a positive blood type if
they're not present then you have a
negative blood type o Rh negative blood
may be given to patients with either Rh
negative or Rh positive blood types
providing their primary a B or o blood
types matches as we talked about
previously
however Rh positive blood will only be
accepted by someone who also has Rh
positive blood I know this complicates
things somewhat but here's a handy table
that shows you which donor blood types
can be accepted by which recipient blood
types so you can refer to it if you ever
find yourself having to give an
emergency blood transfusion you're
welcome in some cases if a mother with
Rh negative blood is carrying a fetus
with r hate positive blood the mothers
antibodies can cross the wall of the
placenta and attack the unborn baby this
is a condition known as hemolytic
disease of the newborn some cultures
believe that blood type actually
reflects an individual personality just
like some people use astrological signs
in the West
in Japan your blood type is believed
to hold information about your
personality temperament and
compatibility with others although this
is not supported by modern science the
belief is so strong that in Japan you're
highly likely to be asked what blood
type you are when you interview for a
new job or go on a date with a potential
partner if you've ever played a Japanese
video game especially an RPG you might
have noticed the character descriptions
in the game's manual include the
character's blood type right alongside
features such as their name gender and
height you might think it's strange that
the game developers have even thought
about what blood type the game
characters are what blood type
personality association is so strong in
Japanese culture that it's considered
completely normal although it's
interesting to learn about there's no
need to keep a card in your wallet or
get a tattoo seeing what blood type you
are in case you're in a near-fatal
accident and need to receive blood
because these days blood type tests are
so fast and efficient that it's quicker
and more accurate for the doctors to run
a test than to go rummaging for your
wallet to find out your blood type the
most common blood type is o-positive o+
types make up 40% of the population
conversely a b- is the rarest blood type
only 1% of the world are a b- only 9% of
the population have de precios
and always in need o-negative blood type
if you do possess o negative blood you
should feel quite empowered because it's
the only blood type that can be safely
given to every human on the planet
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you